The variational quantum iggon solver or VQE is one of the earliest hybrid quantum classical algorithms and it's
interesting for several reasons. First, as we'll see in this video, it is a promising approach for some types of problems. Secondly, it's important
historically and has paved the way for many enhanced algorithms such as adapt VQE.
And finally, VQE is fairly simple. It's easy to understand what the quantum and classical computers do in this algorithm
and how they interact. There are four main components of a VQE calculation.
First, there's an operator, often a Hamiltonian, which we'll call H, that describes a property of the system that
you wish to optimize. Another way of saying this is that you're seeking the igen vector of this operator that
corresponds to the minimum IGEN value. We often call that igen vector the ground state.
Next, there's an anzz word meaning approach. This is a quantum circuit that prepares a quantum state approximating
the igen vector you're seeking. Really, the Anzots is a family of quantum circuits because some of the gates in
the Anzots are parameterized. That is, they are fed a parameter which we can vary. This family of quantum circuits
can prepare a family of quantum states approximating the ground state.
Next, we need an estimator, a means of estimating the expectation value of the operator H over the current variational
quantum state. Sometimes what we really care about is simply this expectation value, which we
call a cost function. Other times we care about a more complicated function that can still be written starting from
one or more expectation values.
Finally, we need a classical optimizer, an algorithm that varies parameters to try to minimize this cost function.
Let's outline the problem we want to solve and the general approach before addressing how quantum plays a role. We
can cast many optimization problems critical to science and industry as matrix value problems. Commonly, you
want the minimum igen value of your matrix and the igen vector that corresponds to it. The matrix H could be
a Hamiltonian describing the energy of a physical system. And the minimum igen value would be the ground state energy
E0 and the igen vector would be the corresponding quantum ground state often denoted SI sub0.
Or the matrix could describe a complicated cost function associated with combinatorial optimization problems
such as in logistics and the igen state s subopt would be an optimal solution of
the problem like a binary string labeling a cut in a graph of a distribution network. In practice it's
common to hear the term Hamiltonian used for all matrices of interest even outside the physical sciences. Let's say
we're interested in a matrix with n rows and n columns. Such problems can be solved quickly and exactly using
classical solvers for n up to a few hundred or thousand with no assumptions made about the matrix. For sparse
matrices, those with mostly zeros as entries, this can be much larger with n as high as a billion even on a laptop.
But for truly enormous problems that exceed these numbers, approximate or heristic methods are often required.
The larger the matrix and the less sparse, the less tractable the problem and the more clever tricks must be employed. Suppose your matrix is so
large that exact diagonalization is not an option. Suppose further that you know enough about your problem that you can
make some guesses about the overall structure of the target state and you want to probe states similar to your
initial guess to see if your cost or energy can be lowered further. This is a variational approach and it's one method
that is used when exact diagonalization is not an option using a classical computer. This would work as follows.
First, you make a guess state with some parameters theta that you will vary.
Although this initial guess could be random, that is not advisable. We want to use knowledge of the problem at hand
to tailor our guess as much as possible.
Second, we would calculate the expectation value of the operator with the system in that state.
Third, we would alter the variational parameters and repeat.
Fourth, we would use accumulated information about the landscape of possible states in your variational subspace to make better and better
guesses and approach the target state.
The variational principle guarantees that our variational state cannot yield an igen value lower than that of the
target ground state. So the lower the expectation value, the better our approximation of the ground state. Let's
talk about the difficulty of each step in this approach.
Setting or updating parameters is computationally easy. The difficulty there is in selecting useful physically
motivated initial parameters. Using accumulated information from prior iterations to update parameters in such
a way that you approach the ground state is non-trivial. But classical optimization algorithms exist that do
this quite efficiently. This classical optimization is only expensive because it may require many
iterations. In the worst case, the number of iterations may scale exponentially with n.
The most computationally expensive single step is almost certainly the expectation value of your matrix using a
given state. The n byn matrix must act on the n element vector which corresponds to order n squared
multiplication operations in the worst case. This must be done at each iteration of parameters. For extremely
large matrices, this has high computational cost. Now imagine relegating this portion of the
calculation to a quantum computer. Instead of calculating this expectation value, you estimate it by preparing the
state s of theta on the quantum computer using your variational anzots and then making measurements.
Let's pick that apart a bit. H is generally not easy to measure. For example, it could be made up of many
non-commuting poly x y and z operators.
But H can be written as a linear combination of terms H subalpha each of which is easily measurable. For example,
poly operators or groups of bitwise commuting poly operators. The
expectation value of H over the state S is the weighted sum of expectation values of the constituent terms H alpha.
This expression holds for any state s but we will specifically be using it with our variational state s of theta.
Each of the terms h alpha can be measured m times yielding measurement samples s subalpha j with j running from
1 to m and returns an expectation value and a standard deviation. We can sum
these terms and propagate errors through the sum.
This requires no largecale multiplication nor any process that necessarily scales like n squ. Instead,
it requires multiple measurements on the quantum computer. If you don't need too many of those, this approach could be
efficient. And that's the quantum part of VQE. But let's talk about reasons why this might not be efficient. One reason
for many measurements is to reduce the statistical uncertainty in your estimates for very high precision
calculations. Another reason is the number of poly strings required to span your entire matrix. Because poly matrices plus the
identity span the space of all operators of a given dimension, we are guaranteed
that we can write our matrix of interest as a weighted sum of poly operators as we did before. Here C alpha is a
numerical coefficient and H alpha is a string of poly operators acting on all the cubits describing your system.
H alpha would have a form like this where the nth poly operator from the right acts on the nth cubit. So we can
measure our operator by measuring a series of poly operators. But we cannot measure all of those poly operators
simultaneously. Poly operators excluding the identity do not commute with each other if they are
associated with the same cubit. For example, we can measure I Z IIZ and ZZ
XZ simultaneously because we can measure I and Z simultaneously for the third
cubit. And we can know I and X simultaneously for the first cubit. But we cannot
measure all Z's and Z zz ZX simultaneously because Z and X do not
commute and both act on the zeroth cubit.
So we decompose our matrix H into a sum of poly's acting on different cubits.
Some elements of that sum can be measured all at once. We call this a group of commuting polies. Depending on
how many non-commuting terms there are, we may need many such groups. Call the number of such groups of commuting
polyst.
If ngcp is small, this could work well.
If h has millions of groups, this will not be useful. You record the expectation value or the cost function
for the set of parameters theta used in your state and then you update the parameters over time. You could use the
expectation values or cost function values you've estimated to approximate a gradient of your cost function in the
subspace of states sampled by your anzots.
Both gradient-based and gradient-free classical optimizers exist. both suffer from potential trainability issues like
multiple local minima and large regions of parameter space with near zero gradient called barren plateaus.
So will VQE solve all your toughest problems? No. But being better at all calculations was never the point. We've
shifted what determines the computational cost. Look at what we've traded. We've shifted from a process
whose complexity depends only on matrix dimension to one that depends on required precision and the number of
non-commuting poly operators that make up the matrix. The last bit has no analog in classical computing.
Based on these new dependencies for sparse matrices or matrices involving few non-commuting polystrings, this
process may be useful. This is the case for systems of interacting spins. For example, for dense matrices, it may be
less useful. We know, for example, that chemical systems often have Hamiltonians that involve hundreds, thousands, even
millions of polystrings. There has been interesting work done to reduce this number of terms, but
chemical systems may be better suited to some of the other algorithms we'll discuss in this course.
Effective use of VQE also requires that we know attributes of our target state and can select a good physically
motivated initial state as well as a good anzot with relatively few variational parameters. This can be
quite challenging. VQE demonstrates how the strengths of classical and quantum computers can be combined
without adding more recent methods. VQE does not help us solve problems that are intractable for classical computers, but
it continues to play a role in algorithm development. And VQE also teaches us that transferring a step from classical
to quantum computers is neither better nor worse for all purposes. Rather, it
changes what factors determine the efficiency of your algorithm. This is an important general lesson in quantum
classical hybrid computing.